the folks in the uk and ireland who
enjoy premier league soccer which by the
way returned to nbcsn recently they
don't wear helmets so it's not an issue
yeah but it is an issue in the nfl and
what you need to know this morning
happens
directly in the heart of hard knocks
country although i have a feeling we're
not going to hear much about this on
tuesday night's edition of the program
antonio brown threatening to retire from
the national football league if he's not
allowed to wear his helmet of choice the
problem is his helmet of choice is
outdated it's more than 10 years old it
can't be recertified by the independent
helmet certification industry that
allows this thing to continue to be worn
it's too late it's done now antonio
brown has to pick another helmet from
the approved menu of nfl and
nflpa authorized helmets he refuses to
do it he's filed a grievance a hearing
happened on friday and a decision is
expected this week chris i can't imagine
he's going to win
and i have
you know with him i have no idea what
this guy's going to do i would like to
think that if he loses he just picks a
helmet and moves on because if he
doesn't he's given up 30 million dollars
in guaranteed money this year and next
year this is crazy this is ridiculous
and i hope there's someone out there
that can talk some sense into antonio
brown yeah if he quits football over the
uh the helmet thing then then
crazyville's got a new mayor okay i know
that uh like no joke there but the the
first thing i think we got a hit on mike
was this whole thing and then him now
trying to hold the nfl liable right to
say that if he does get hurt wearing a
new helmet he wants to hold them loud i
mean you as a lawyer that's the first
thing i want to ask is there any grounds
to stand on there that doesn't seem to
make sense that oh i'm going to wear a
safer helmet and if i get hurt in that
i'm going to hold the nfl liable as
compared to
i'm wearing this old junky one that's
now been outlawed because it's more than
10 years old uh correct me if i'm wrong
there does that make any sense
it makes no sense whatsoever and here's
the saying and i wrote about this
yesterday mentioned in the radio hour
early in law school they teach you if
you have the facts paddle on the facts
if you have the law pound on the law if
you have neither pound on the table and
this argument that was fashioned by his
legal team and deliberately leaked to
daniel kaplan in the athletic to try to
create i guess some sort of public
support for this idea that the nfl is
going to be in trouble if antonio brown
has to wear one of these other approved
helmets after millions of dollars of
research from the nfl and the nfl pa
jointly working together to identify the
safest possible headgear for players
this this notion that if you don't let
me wear my old outdated helmet and i get
injured wearing one of the helmets that
you have determined is safe for use or
at least as safe as it can possibly be
given that it's football and injuries
are potentially going to happen that
you're going to be responsible for that
it's chris let me just boil it down let
me boil it down to one issue this is
what here's what's going to be
impossible for antonio brown to prove if
it ever comes to it he's never going to
be able to prove that the injury that
happened wearing one of the nfl and nfl
pa approved helmets wouldn't have
happened if he was wearing his crappy
old outdated helmet that is too old to
be certified for continued use how do
it's called causation how do you prove
that the decision to force him to wear
this helmet caused the injury and here's
the bigger picture too put it in a
different setting i mentioned this on
the radio side if you have a guy who's
working in a construction setting and
he's got this hard hat from the 70s that
he's got some connection to it's just
lucky hard hat right but it's unsafe and
his his union has worked with management
to come up with a safe
alternative that he must wear it's part
of the equipment you must wear this yes
and he says no i'm not going to do it
i'm going to file a grievance let me
wear my crappy old outdated helmet
that's how ridiculous this is and folks
here's the bottom line if he doesn't
want to wear the helmet he doesn't have
to wear the helmet he doesn't have to
play football he can give up the 30
million dollars if he truly does not
want to wear the helmet that's what
makes this so crazy chris yes extremely
crazy and and i'll say this as a
football player
i i know that we are creatures of habits
i certainly was too i love my own you
know you know my own style of shoulder
pads and my own thigh pads that i wanted
to wear and you know you like everything
exactly what makes you feel comfortable
one and then two you love things that
you had success in to
continue to wear those things because
you think oh gosh a little superstition
and you think that might bring you some
good luck here or there now okay i get
all that okay that's that's great but
these new helmets first off they're more
comfortable than these 10 plus year old
helmets that antonio brown's wearing
plus i think the other aspect that i
just think is funny is antonio brown
he's all into you know being faster
being quicker doing all those things i
mean it is documented that all these new
helmets are much lighter really than any
of these old helmets that i used to wear
or the one that antonio brown's wearing
too so even from a competitive
standpoint it makes sense to wear the
new helmet let alone the safety uh
impact of the whole thing too
and and to me i think that's what's also
just kind of funny about this because
you would think antonio brown would want
to feel good and take a pound or two off
of his body so he could feel just a
little faster
and if you're watching on nbcs center
sky sports you'll see the b-roll
industry term of antonio brown in his
shut air advantage it was discontinued
by shut in 2011 and that's the problem
the version that he has is more than 10
years old and can't be re-certified and
watch this one here see what he does he
checks his look in the mirror you see
that chris yes this is a vanity play in
part he doesn't like how he looks in
these other helmets these newfangled
helmets make players look like the great
gazoo
he doesn't want to look like the great
gazoo he wants to look like a b and and
the other side of it is don't tell me
what to do no one has told this guy what
to do ever since he became a star player
he hasn't heard the word no from anyone
and when it finally fell apart in
pittsburgh he was able to fashion it
into you didn't break up with me i broke
up with you you didn't want to get rid
of me i wanted to get rid of you and he
got his way and he got 30 million in
guaranteed money from the raiders so i
think it's a combination of vanity and
ego that is driving this guy
with a healthy dose of flat out
stupidity that is preventing him from
recognizing all he's got to do is show
up and wear a helmet and he gets his 30
million and and
that's how simple it is he doesn't have
to play well he doesn't have to be the
old a b he just has to show up for work
wear the helmet step on the field and
he's going to make 30 million dollars
over the next two years no matter how
well or poorly he plays well
this is now the next question because
you you kind of hit on it he's a master
manipulator we've already seen that i
mean this is the guy that i mean as you
just mentioned squeezed his way out of
pittsburgh and pulled off a deal that we
have never seen anybody pull off in the
nfl i mean true
gangster move for lack of a better
phrase right there to do that but the
next thing i want to ask you
do you think that all that this is a
you know a scam a farce or whatever just
to take away from the foot issue that
maybe he's embarrassed about i just i'm
just throwing things out there i don't
know i'm trying to dive into the mind of
antonio brown is it a distraction
because he is embarrassed does that
cross your mind at all or do you think
he's
crazy altogether
it's definitely been a distraction to
the frozen foot issue that's for damn
sure because we're not talking about the
frozen feet but you know apparently this
helmet thing has been lingering since
april i mean i can't help but wonder
whether or not the frozen foot thing has
been a distraction to the helmet issue
yeah i i don't know i mean it's
distraction on top of distraction it's
impossible to unpack it all and figure
out exactly what's going on but you know
when he walked into that cryotherapy
chamber in france chris he knew that
helmet thing was looming what better way
than to delay the inevitable
than to maybe come out of there with
feet that got a little uh uh you know
over frozen in the cryotherapy machine
and all of a sudden you can't practice
while you work this thing out i look i i
don't know whether or not he's capable
of that kind of a diabolical plan the
whole thing really is one of the
craziest stories that i can remember and
i know the recency of it makes it seem a
little more nutty it's still going to be
something that when we look back on it 5
10 15 20 years from now we're going to
say man was that nutty the guys yes the
guy's got to wear a helmet and player
after player has have transitioned into
these helmets that's how the world works
if you're playing football the helmets
improve they become safer at least
relatively safe because there's not
there's no way to completely eliminate
the possibility of a concussion but you
can still make a safer helmet that is
easier uh for the player to use like you
said it can be lighter and this whole
thing just it boggles the mind that
antonio brown has found himself in this
spot and chris i can't help but wonder
whether it's some level this is also an
attempt to build in an excuse ahead of
time
if he isn't a b anymore if it's you know
the offense the team derek carr hey it's
not me it's this stupid helmet i'd still
be a b if i could wear my old helmet i
can't see the ball i don't feel like
myself anymore this just doesn't work
it's not me it's the helmet yeah i i
mean
i don't know if i'll go that far i'm not
throwing anything out yeah i'm not gonna
say you're crazy there because uh i
never thought well we should be sitting
here talking about this 12 minutes into
a show on a monday and it's still the
same subject or even this subject to
begin with and i really hey another
thing just to unpack this whole thing
you know gosh what are the oakland
raiders and management thinking right
now you know i mean they they got to be
a little bit in this like this funk of
oh gosh what did we get ourselves into
we knew this guy had some personality
issues and was tough to handle uh but i
would love to be in a fly in a room with
mike mayok and john gruden right now
because we've heard it's been late for
meetings and all these other antics and
then of course not being out there for
practice and he's got the raiders by the
proverbial you know what down below
right now because
yeah
because
they've they vested so much into them
with money and sold them as their guy
and this is our new toy and the offense
is going to be around him and he's the
greatest practice player i've ever seen
so
from that standpoint too the raiders are
going to be a little tongue-tied because
they got to be careful what they say
they want to make sure this works
because it looks bad on the coaches in
the gm if it doesn't
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports